let's first talk about
shiba inu if we can also known
as sheba token code shib
for contact shiba unu was created in
august 2020
modeled off of doshcoin by the anonymous
founder
known as ryoshi on may 10th
this year it had a market capitalization
of
over 13 billion
uh maybe you can explain this but in a
crazy move you were given
half of shibs uh total supply
you uh burned aka destroyed ninety
percent of it
that's worth 6.7
billion dollars and you donated 10
percent
that's worth 1.2 billion
at the time to an uh india coven 19
relief fund
saying you don't want to be the locus of
this much power
this is uh fascinating why
and how were you able to walk away from
this much money and this much power
so i i should probably start by yeah
giving
some of the backstory around you know
these coins and this concept of giving
me coins
uh so you know first of all you know
shiba you knew as you said is this
a kind of knockoff of dogecoin right and
douchecoin was this
initial and kind of fun coin that was
created back i think around 2014 or so
and it was just created by jackson
palmer and like put it out as a joke for
a couple of hours and a community formed
around it
and at the beginning people didn't take
it very seriously
i actually remember putting about 25 000
into doge sometime around 2016 and i
just remember
uh thinking to myself like okay how
am i going to explain my to my mom that
i just invested 25 000
into dog coins and like what even are
dog coins like the only
interesting thing about this coin is
that there's you know a logo of a dog
somewhere um but you know of course that
ended up being one of the best
investments i've ever made and
it did really well and then at the end
of 2020 elon musk of course you know
started talking about dogecoin
and the market cap just like shot up to
about 50
billion dollars actually and it shot up
multiple times right like the first time
it went up from about
0.8 cents to about like seven cents
and this just happened all in one day
and i remember um this was when
i was still in singapore in the middle
of uh
kovid and it i saw that the price just
went up by a thousand percent
and i was like oh my god my doge is
worth like
a lot and so i immediately
called up some of my friends and told
them to like drop everything in scramble
and i just sold half the dosh and
i got 4.3 million dollars donated the
proceeds to give directly
and a few hours after i did this the
price dropped back down from about seven
cents to four cents right so i managed
to sell the doge at the top and i
remember
just feeling like i was such an amazing
trader but then of course
you know the price went up from four
cents then to seven and then 50 and just
like doge becoming this big phenomenon
where there's even a lot of people that
have heard of those that have not heard
of ethereum is just like something
even i wasn't predicting right and so
after that of course you know we have
doge and then
people are thinking well you know if the
leading dog token is worth 50 billion
dollars then surely
the second largest dog token deserves
you know at least seven or eight billion
right because i i feel like that's the
kind of what the mindset of these
uh shiba people is um so then of course
they did this other gimmick right where
they gave me half the shiba token supply
um they were actually not the first
projects to do this uh so
around the end of 2020 there was this
weird project
called teller it's like t-e-l-l-o-r i
think they're a chain-link competitor or
something like this
but i remember they just like dumped
fifty thousand dollars worth of their
token into my wallet
and then they had their twitter army and
just like basically run around saying
look look at vitalik's wallet vitalik
holds towers he's one of us he's a
supporter
and as soon as i discovered this i just
like publicly
sold the teller tokens on you to swap
and this created a bit of a twitter
splat
now the shiva people were more clever
the shiva people instead of dumping to
that wallet
they dumped to my cold wallet right so
in
a cryptocurrency right there's this
concept of like cold wallets and hot
well it's basically
like the thing that actually owns your
money is like this
80 digit number called a private key
right and a hot wallet is when that
private key is just stored in memory on
your computer on your phone really easy
to access cold wallet means it's either
on written down on a piece of paper or
it's uh
on a computer that's just never accessed
the internet right so cold is very
inconvenient but
cold is also much more secure right
because even if that computer has some
like viruses on it like it's it's like
air-gapped it's not actually going to be
able to upload it
so this cold wallet and like all the
money's out of the cold wallet so it's
safe for me to talk about my setup now
right but it was
a laptop that was sitting in canada and
i also had
two pieces of paper where i wrote down
two numbers on those two pieces of paper
one was with me one was in canada and if
you add those two numbers together you
get the private key
so because of covid travel restrictions
and you know this is
cold wallets in canada like it's very
difficult for me to
um actually access it right and i'm not
sure if they knew this maybe they just
got lucky but basically they
you know sent a lot of uh these dog
tokens
into this wallet where i it was very
difficult for me to access it but then i
saw these dot co
tokens i saw more and more people
talking about them and then at some
point i realized
i realized that like hey these things
are worth billions of dollars and like
you know there's lots of really good
things that you could do with that
amount of money and it would actually be
a waste to just like see a go so i made
the
decision that like i would actually
power through and figure out how to like
safely like basically get my private key
um i actually had to
call up my family tell them to read out
their number off of their piece of paper
i uh entered that into a fresh
laptop that i bought from target then i
put in my other
number on my piece of paper added the
two numbers together on the computer
there's the key
and at the same time like just scrambled
for two days
setting up a new wallet for to where i
could move my ether safely
like getting people to be multisig
partners just like doing
all sorts of like stuff that you know 10
years ago you would expect to just be
part of a cyberpunk
you know science fiction novel but you
know now it's all real so you're doing
this
all by yourself i essentially most of it
by myself so
you have to keep it secret right and i
needed my family to
um actually like go and read the the
number on their piece of paper
and then i um in my new multisig wallet
like there's
other people that are signatories um but
you know
i'm obviously not gonna reveal any
details beyond that about
so i did this right and i actually
managed to
make get the private key make the first
transaction that would just move all my
ether to the multisig wallet so it's
safe
and then second transact i put the
private key on my main computer then
started
you know like going in and just selling
some of the dog tokens and then just
like giving them to these
different charities now at the time i
actually
did not even like have any idea of how
much you would be able to get right
because like
on paper the dog tokens are seven
billion dollars but like in reality it's
a very liquid market you know
are you going to crash it by yeah and
after you sell one million worth you're
gonna crash it after 10 million
are you might you actually be able to
get like an entire
200 million i had no idea um
so i definitely was just of the mindset
like okay i mean
i'll sell a bit maybe get some eath and
then you know donated some youth to give
well donated some to other groups and
then
okay have some dog tokens like i don't
have an easy ability to sell more myself
but then i'll just
like give them to these groups and like
you know hopefully they'll do good
things with them
um it was actually um i actually donated
at 20
and dumped 80 percent um yeah so the
cove
the coved um india group got one batch
and then there's
another group that got another batch and
i don't want to say who they are because
i think that
they want to announce themselves at some
point sure yeah but it's uh
you know you you can see the fact that
these transactions were made on the
blockchain
um but it was uh just
very intriguing interesting and
unexpected and just an insanely crazy
situation it's been a couple of weeks
first of all thank you for uh helping me
uh hang up some curtains this is
this is a first for the podcast and uh
shows uh that you're truly a special
person
um to be willing to help but now a
couple weeks later do you
regret any aspect of that decision um
i'm sure there are some things that i
probably could have done better like
i i was actually i was actually talking
to some of these charities and i was
impressed by just
how much money they managed to get out
of selling some of these coins
so i i probably could have done better
by just like
talking more with the traders and
actually ensuring that like
you know that they can do a better job
of maximizing the
the value of uh of uh all of them but
like you know it was a very stressful
time and i did have to act quickly like
i yeah
i did manage to you know make a lot of
the donations before
like a few a few days before the great
crypto crash happened
uh so it was and
it's difficult to like obviously there's
parallel universes in which i did better
but at the same time
there's also lots of parallel universes
where because i hesitated more
and tried to spend more time thinking i
missed the opportunity uh
so you know on that it's like a luck of
the draw and i'm just
you know happy that uh it was
everything was uh able to turn out as
well as it did but psychologically
you mentioned stress how hard was it
uh it was stressful right i think well
one of the really stressful parts was
just the fact that
i had to basically move all of my funds
you know including the 325 000 ether
from one cold wallet into another hot
wallet
or sorry into another multi-sig wallet
um
and you know maybe the multisig wallet
had a bug in it maybe
there's like some mistake i'll make in
the middle that causes the the funds to
get lost like you know
that's that part was stressful and i
was definitely stressing out for two
days i'm you know triple checking the
new wallet i even did a bit of an audit
of the code myself
i wrote my own javascript adapt to make
confirmations because gnosis safe didn't
work with the status wallet well um
so there was definite that whole thing
was definitely a bit of a marathon
um i was also a kind of definitely a bit
worried about or
uncertain i guess how the public and you
know including the coin communities
would perceive the whole thing
um but i was actually impressed like i
yeah for every poster that was saying
like no
you know why yeah why did vitalik like
rug pull on us he was simple
his wallet was supposed to be a burn
address you know there's like 10 people
that are like
oh you know i thought i was just in this
because it's a
it's a fun pyramid gambling thing but
instead i ended up being part of this
you know great public good thing for
humanity and that's like even more
amazing
so the i the amount of that that i got
was very
impressive so you know all in all let me
know i think the dog people did great
the dog people is there something you
can extend to the bigger picture of it
in the principles you apply to making
this decision is there some
principles philosophies that you apply
also to uh
the decisions you make around ethereum
um
um i think a big one for me is just
this idea that crypto um you know isn't
just an opportunity to give people like
slightly better ways to
save value and all of these things like
it's also an opportunity to
like basically create these like new
digital
institutions that could serve the public
good in new ways
and and that's something that i've been
interested in for a long time i might
actually even have this
article in bitcoin magazine back in 2014
where i basically
suggested this idea that you know you
would have coins that represent causes
and like people would just like buy and
accept
those coins because they support those
causes so i think it's called
markets institutions and currencies a
new form of social incentivization or
something like that like
and i'm sure you can find it and throw
it in the links um yeah
the so that was interesting to kind of
see becoming real and like in general
right i think
you know public goods are very important
and on the internet public goods are
even more important right like every
single lex freedman podcast is just
on youtube and you know anyone can go
and see it like there's no way for you
to like
you know sell it and uh so that some
people can see it but then other people
can't see it like you know you could do
that but then
you'd obviously be you know reducing
your impact so thank you for making the
uh
uh the amazing lex treatment podcast
still freely available
well that's actually a tense thing is uh
how do you do it in a way that's not uh
controlled in a centralized fashion
because actually
youtube feels free and open but it
nevertheless is one company making
centralized decisions and
the first time i realized youtube was
not forever is when
a lot of the joe rogan experienced
library was pulled from youtube
as part of the spotify deal it made me
realize
we need to it's like the realization
that fiat money is
centralized is uh realizing that you
know
the they this is not forever and you
might want to come up with schemes
to distribute it to uh decentralize
the control of it in a way that audio
for podcasters was just an rss feed
exactly yeah and i think one of the kind
of philosophical things that i hope to
achieve is kind of
decouple the concept of public goods
which are
incredibly important and are the
lifeblood of modern civilization
from the the idea that their nick is
is or can be one central organization
that represents the public
and like perfectly under uh understands
and can impose their idea of what is the
good
right like it's when people talk about
public goods like
it just often comes with this baggage of
uh you know either centralization or
conformism
and i think like it doesn't have to
right like uh often
the most important public goods are the
ones that are created by
you know the crazy individualists that
disagree with everyone else
uh so trying to make this kind of
synthesis where you know you combine the
values of decentralization and the
values of open source
but you're not naive about it and like
you know you realize
um that for these things to be produced
there needs to be a way for it to be
sustainable there needs to be
some way of supporting people who are
working these projects but at the same
time you want to
avoid that turning into a vector of
centralization
like trying to sort of
get all of the good things without the
bad things to me that's
a yeah a big part of
sort of what my grand experiment in
crypto is about and
like we are doing things in different
kinds of things for this right like
there's
the the git coin grants quadratic
funding in the ethereum ecosystem
um there's i mean obviously these uh dog
coins that just happens
like i guess accidentally um there's
other projects
um that like for example you know
uniswap has
um their uniswap dao that just has a
huge amount of funding and
like we haven't seen yet how that's
going to be deployed but you know it
could be
potentially deployed to do lots of
really good and amazing things
do you see ethereum as essentially a
mechanism
to uh fight for social causes
um i definitely see ethereum as
being a mechanism to
fight for definitely some some specific
things that are
that are social causes um like
just you know the fact of creating an
open financial system that anyone can
participate in no matter where they are
in the world that's a social cause
um just you know giving people the
ability to
organize and create projects even if
it's five people in five different
countries i think
that kind of inclusiveness i think
that's a social cause and it's a core
uh a core crypto value um it's
but then at the same time like the other
important and if part of the magic of
ethereum that you have to balance that
against is that it is also this
open platform where ultimately you know
the thing that go
the things that are on ethereum is just
the things that the community makes of
it
you